for as long as i'm sure most of us can
remember we've always known the big
three of shonen jump
naruto and naruto shippuden the series
that implanted itself
into the childhood of millions of anime
and non-anime fans alike as a staple of
the shonen genre
one piece the everlasting monolith that
shows no sign of stopping
outpacing all other manga in the history
of japan for the most amount of copies
sold
by an outrageous margin and bleach
the younger brother of the three
siblings who gets praised for trying
the big three used to be inescapable no
matter where you went
whether it was conventions or manga
stores you couldn't help but be grabbed
by the enormous grasp that the ninjas
shinigami and pirates had on the anime
world
and animated world at that seeing as
most exposure came from the three anime
adaptations being on mainstream
television even in western countries
but as blichonarto ended one piece of
course still going strong as ever
for many years now questions have been
raised of what will be the next big
three
my hero academia has been dominating the
market for a couple years now
recently rivaled by the darker jiu-jitsu
kaisen and while the black clover anime
gets a lot of flack the manga continues
going strong with almost 300 chapters
detailing the adventures of asta
becoming the hokage
wait no that's not right pirate king
number one hero
oh oh here it is the wizard king of
course
and even though there's smaller names
like boruto and chainsaw man in the
reserves of shonen jump
we of course have to acknowledge the
outstanding and unprecedented explosion
of demon slayer
starting in 2019 and continuing to the
present day with the recently released
mugen train movie worldwide
so today i'll be discussing what are the
next big three
which series have the potential to live
up to that name and
also why the original title of big three
can
probably never be replicated again as
anime moves on to a new era
there will be anime that surpass them
i'm sure which will be what i try and
explain today
but before we get into it subscribing to
the channel would be a huge help since a
lot of my viewers
aren't yet i would appreciate the
support let's go
now everyone knows the original big
three so there's no reason to go into
too much depth in any of them
individually
but the big three did set an important
standard as a collective
that is for what a good long-running
shonen should aspire to do
the demon trapped inside the teen boy
from naruto that we've seen in black
clover and jiu jitsu kaisen
the journey to become the head honcho
from both naruto and one piece that we
see
in one way or another in almost every
shonen nowadays
whether it's just becoming stronger
working up the ranks of an organization
or being just as on the nose like in
black clover to become the wizard king
and these things always get made fun of
or teased mainly because we see these
tropes so much
but of course we see them so much
because frankly
they work they attract audiences and
keep them entranced in this journey to
the top
to beat and tame the monster inside of
you and prove everyone else that you can
do it
which leads me to my first point which
is the creation of mainstream
shonen tropes by the big three granted
naruto one piece and bleach weren't the
first manga or anime to have this shown
in pizzazz to make this well known
dragon ball z yuyu hakusho and fist of
the north star are some of the original
trailblazers for this genre
but with the combined power and
popularity of the big three amongst
audiences that extended even to
non-anime watchers
it set the standard for what would come
these journeys cemented themselves in
the lives and childhoods of so many
youths
which is something that is difficult to
replicate as time goes on
i elaborated on this in my video about
ecchi anime which you should check out
i'm pretty proud of it
but the broad idea is basically that as
time goes on
anime continues to get more
oversaturated and competitive
with dozens of new titles being released
every season
and as this happens the feeling of
originality does gradually disappear
not to say that new anime aren't
original at all but comparisons are
always being drawn to older or more
popular shows
and this puts new manga or anime that
aspire to become the new big three
in a difficult position as making a name
for themselves is very hard among the
hundreds
of other anime aiming for that same spot
but
of course disregarding the big three's
feeling of originality
the nostalgia that probably can never be
replicated again
there are certainly new manga that have
reached similar levels of popularity or
at least
show potential for it the one i feel
obligated to mention first
is of course demonstrator
demon slayer came out of 2019 as not
only the biggest anime but the biggest
manga of the year which is certainly a
feat to mention when you're up against
the immovable colossus that is one piece
i mean it's the only one remaining of
the big three for a reason
beating out one piece by 2 million sales
was already a notable achievement in
but its absolutely unprecedented impact
on the manga community in 2020 would
soon come to blow that
out of the park in 2020 the demon slayer
manga sold
over 82 million copies that's right
the difference between 12 million and 10
million in 2019
in only a year became a difference of 75
million copies
there is no doubt that this year was one
that will forever remain in history
books for manga and anime
fans especially considering the other
surprise that came that same year
that the demon slayer manga was ending
and this brings in my second point
the longevity of the big three granted i
don't personally think it's ever a good
idea to stretch a manga out if it's
reached its satisfactory ending
this is definitely something that bleach
suffered from after the irankar downfall
arc
something that bothered anime and manga
readers alike
but even if it ended here it still would
have finished at 423 chapters
a very long serialization period but
demon slayer
ended only at 200 far shorter than
probably anyone even expected
but while the manga was shortened the
anime continues going strong as
mugentrain has surpassed spirited away
in japan
and worldwide now as the highest
grossing anime film of all time
just adding to the list of accolades for
the series
but there's something kind of terrifying
about knowing that there is
in fact an end already in store for the
series
that there's already a deadline even one
piece which is supposedly over 60
done a stat that came out like a year or
two ago
in one piece time that's like another
five years minimum of the manga being
serialized
what i'm trying to say is that there was
a certain lasting impact that the big
three had
on the anime and manga community not
just because of the enormous levels of
popularity that they reached that demon
slayer has done as well
if not surpassed but because they
continued to come out and reel more
people in as the manga and anime got
into more diverse arcs
i don't think demon slayer's popularity
will go down anytime soon of course
but instead of following the legacy of
the big three it's creating an entirely
different path
than them instead and on that note let's
get into the manga that are still going
and show the most potential to become
the i guess i'll call them the next big
three for now
my hero black clover and jujutsu kaisen
just as the world realized that demon
slayer was ending and reluctantly
struggled to find a new replacement in
the new big three
jujutsu kaisen took the anime world by
storm
and these three manga though i don't
personally read black clover just to
do my hero definitely have a lot of
promise for the future to come
both my hero and jiu-jitsu kaisen have
entered into game-changing arcs for this
series in the manga
and honestly completely turned the story
sideways
coming out of the intense and incredible
shibuya district arc in jujutsu kaisen
and paranormal liberation war arc in my
hero
though my hero has recently entered its
quote-unquote final arc
similar to one piece that could still be
a matter of years to come
so i wouldn't really say that the series
is ending anytime soon
and this brings me to my last point
which is the new standard that these
manga are setting
straying away from that shadow of the
big three
i don't think anything can necessarily
follow in the footsteps of the big three
like i was saying earlier
but we can certainly change and improve
on what they lacked
jiu jitsu kaisen though it's not as
evident yet in the anime as it is in the
manga
is way darker than any of the big three
or my hero
and is certainly bringing an aspect to
mainstream shonen that anime watchers
aren't yet used to in this genre my hero
is also
in my opinion going in a very unique
route in the last arc
and arc to come one that while not
necessarily completely new to us readers
can and will definitely take the already
popular manga and anime onto further
more mature levels and i mean i don't
read it but i'm assuming that being
almost 300 chapters deep
black clover is probably doing the same
thing
and so i think anime and manga is kind
of moving on from the big three
which are commonly associated with you
know our childhoods and growing up
of course one piece is an exception to a
lot of these generalizations because it
just keeps getting bigger and
better but the new big three if you want
to call them that
are bringing a level maturity to shonen
jump that i'm really excited to see
one that reflects the over saturation of
anime nowadays
and the growth of shonen from just being
a kid with a demon inside of him
becoming the hokage
to much more mature and in-depth
exploration into these darker tones
[Music]
and just as an endnote i didn't intend
for any of this to make any of the anime
i've talked about seem better or worse
than
any other if you felt that way i think
that my main point was that there's a
certain connotation with the big three
and their legacy that i don't think can
ever be recreated
instead modern anime will make their own
name i'm sure
and be remembered in time for that what
do you guys think
are you excited about the future of
shonen jump and anime
what do you think about jiu-jitsu kaisen
my hero black clover all of it
leave a comment as always this has been
the anime culture corner
i hope you enjoyed the video don't
forget to like and subscribe for future
in-depth show
manga and character analyses
you